now that we know that we can treat units
algebraically let's see if we can use
that knowledge to figure out what the
units of a variable might be from some
formula so let's say that i'm given this
formula that capital k
is equal to lowercase b
over
s squared
and let's say
let's say
that we are also told we are also told
that b is going to be in centimeters
and s
s
is going to be in
grams per
centimeter so that's the units of s is
grams per centimeter b is in centimeters
what are the units or what is the unit
of k or the units of k going to be and i
encourage you to pause this video and
think about this
well let's try it out with just some
value and some values for b and s and
see what happens let's say that b
let's say that b
is equal to one
centimeter and i'm just using one
because it makes the math really easy
and let's say that s is one gram per
centimeter
so we know that k
so k is going to be equal to
one centimeter that's b
over
one gram per centimeter squared one gram
per centimeter
squared now we've already talked about
the idea that we should treat our units
like algebraic quantities so this should
be equal to
one centimeter
one centimeter over
now you could treat this as 1 squared
times
and this let me rewrite this you could
rewrite this as 1 squared times
grams per centimeter
squared and this just comes out of the
idea that if i have a times b to some
power say the second power that's equal
to a squared
b squared and we also know that if i
have a over b
to some power say squared that's the
same thing as a squared over b squared
so i could rewrite this as this is going
to be equal to
one centimeter
over
one squared is just one one
gram squared per
centimeter
per centimeter squared now what is this
going to be equal to let me write it
over here
well that's going to be one centimeter
in our numerator one centimeter let me
do it in that green color so i can keep
track of things
one centimeter from our numerator
instead of dividing it by one gram
squared per centimeter squared i can
multiply it times the reciprocal of this
so times 1 over
1 over 1 which is just going to be 1.
but let me just write it that way just
so that you get that i'm taking the
reciprocal of 1.
so 1 over 1 times the reciprocal of gram
squared per centimeter squared well
that's just going to be centimeters
squared
per grams squared so what's this going
to be equal to well i have one times one
so if i take the if i take the numeric
parts one times one is just going to be
one
and now remember we can treat the units
algebraically i have a centimeters times
centimeters squared well that's going to
get me to centimeters cubed
centimeters to the third
power
and that's not you know this isn't c
times m to the third r this is
centimeters to the third power you could
write it like this if you wanted to be
clear about it
per and over here we still have grams
squared
per grams squared so the units i just
picked the numbers one arbitrary so the
one isn't what matters here i just pick
those numbers what matters here is what
are the units what are the units for
this formula when b is in centimeters
and s is in grams per centimeters we see
that k
is going to be is going to be expressed
in terms of cubic centimeters
cubic centimeters per gram
per gram squared and i can't tell you
offhand with kind of an intuitive
physical representation of that but you
at least know the units you have cube
cubic centimeters which you can kind of
view as as a volume divided by like it's
a mass squared and a mass squared is a
little bit less intuitive for me but at
least we know what the units of k would
be in this formula given the units of b
and s